bonsoir 98 mille francs pour le divan de
jacques lacan c'est le prix payé par un
mystérieux acheteur cet après midi à
l'hôtel drouot fou le divan du célèbre
psychanalyste été vendu aux enchères la
salle était comble les disciples de
lacan ont bataillé pendant plus d'une
heure pour emporter chez eux un des
objets du maître parmi les groupies
béatrice nivois joseph tual
y at il encore des lacaniens en france
oui au vu de la foule des vrais des faux
collectionneurs des curieux des
acheteurs même de vous qui se sont mués
pourvoir l'acquéreur du célèbre divan de
là quand une personne discrète arrivé en
retard qui s'est enfui dès que le
marteau s'est abattu on est elle des
troubles de personnalité du fétichisme
pour une fois qu'on ne taxera pas
d'actes mal ça mais plutôt d' acte
symbolique pour ce prix le mystérieux
acquéreur prendra possession dès lundi
des célèbres napperons ou ont reposé les
têtes de ceux que le maître recevait
dans son cabinet pourrait penser jacques
la corne moriani blanc de cette vente de
l'ironie façon tous les gens qui
achètent sont les bienvenus chez nous
quels que soient les motifs pour
lesquels ils achètent les acheteurs ont
ils agi consciemment et inconsciemment
en tout cas ils ont mis le prix 18 mille
cinq cents francs pour la table de
travail du maître certains ont juste
surenchéri pour la beauté du geste
pas un événement de la pensée c'est un
événement année anecdotique et en même
temps amusant ça n'a rien de scandaleux
une vente publique la psychanalyse en
france se porte bien en tout cas en
salle des ventes ou en cabinet elle
rapporte